sticky spiced chicken wings Jack here's
a hand please book why because it's your
favorites
yeah wings okay all right let's start
off with the marinade tamarind paste him
first all that into there okay so two
tablespoons of palm sugar please so I
heated sugar it's a natural pasture and
it's perfect for marinades any wings you
think you've eaten so far at the age of
thirteen Oh for a fifty year 50 years
yeah a nice sprinkle of chili flakes
depends how hot you like them don't
forget the girls you know they start
complaining when you get them too hot
how come you love hot food no food so in
there we've got palm sugar tamarind
paste chili flakes some garlic one nice
tablespoon of fish sauce please check
looking really good I'm gonna
tablespoons of oil burning in a nice
little taste very good
right wings in get your hands in there
and start rubbing in the marinade please
okay so the secret now is to coat the
chicken wings then all that marinade
yeah yeah how long do you need them in
sure the longer the better cover that
make them feel more shadow excellent
good job
ideally marinate your wings overnight
but half an hour will be enough to get
the flavors going right it's that
marinated now if you take the trout
people buy the one thank you and then we
go put some tin foil on there
thank you all that in half they stop
them from sticking and the wings from
burning so from there get a moody dipped
in that marinade and try and get the
wing like that and just sort of scoop it
look like that look at that really nice
glaze on there and then just
so that garlic will roast right up all
those wings beautifully done
I can make then ready for the oven 170
25 to 30 minutes yep good man
excellent nice wings are in right to go
with my ultimate Southeast Asian dinner
rice cooked in homemade Thai green curry
paste for the easy green curry paste
roughly chopped coriander
lemongrass
green chilies lime leaf shallots garlic
and ginger a glug of oil and blitz the
pace takes minutes to make but it'll
keep for up to 10 days if covered with
oil and stored in a sealed jar in the
fridge to awaken the flavors lime roll
to release the juice next season with
salt and pepper and blend into a smooth
paste
[Music]
pick the pace until aromatic adding
cooled or leftover rice I love using
fragrant jasmine rice but your standard
long grain rice is great too when
thoroughly heated through serve Thai
green curry paste is so easy to make so
with rice like this it's incredible but
simply add to chicken fish or vegetable
in minutes right now for the green beans
beans in bring the water the ball what's
the first thing I should put in there
beans salt salt so nice pinch of salt in
there yeah so I make an amazing dressing
to Knight tablespoons yep the crunchy
peanut butter please why is it crunchy
I'll give it texture and it will be nice
and sort of chunky green beans in okay
got the rice it's green beans we're
gonna blast them for two two-and-a-half
minutes what is blanching actually mean
blanching means sort of part cooking
okay with a blanch them in boiling water
and then finish them in the pan use the
back of the spoon will be a little
easier please burn off brown sugar and
she goes nice is that little bit too
thick maybe it yeah it is just put a
little touch more soy sauce in there let
it down yeah yeah vinegar nice and I got
a pan on now all my beans
so no tasting you taste it it's so good
oh man hmm Wow
have you got the garlic go there I'm
gonna slice the garlic down like this
keep the knife nice and flat and that
way you'll slice through it will take
your time don't worry about the speed
and technique right first just cut it in
half okay your fingers and then lay the
flat side down so it's nice and sturdy
and that nail they're not out like that
it's just guiding the knife so you can
never cut yourself like that good I'll
drain the beans
nice a little tell a spoon of oil pan
nice and hot it's for a garlic and
people only so give that a little toss
so will you toss it push it down push
away and pull back okay
a little good push it down and gently
though that's take your time
nice so push down and back up that's it
nice so it's getting nice and golden
brown green beans drained and they go in
now to the garlic okay with the rice I
want you now spoon they're dressing the
please
and she goes nice how delicious does
that look Wow what's that he's
qualitative home no waste no waste no
waves but now smell that now doesn't
smell of green beans Thanks how nice is
that
mmm amazing right
that's the rice that's for green beans
now in order to sprinkle some toasted
sesame seeds on top place nice and
generous with a sesame seed
I'll give the beans a little bit of a
crunch now all is left to your favorites
to come out done those being smell
amazing yeah mmm
look at those beauties one for me one
for you Alfie
they're like to sprinkle some spring
onions on top these nice and Jenny's
transformed are very cheap and cheerful
chicken wing
yeah okay I'm over please do not drop
them too much as Gerber nice this is my
ultimate simple Southeast Asian dinner
sticky spicy chicken wings Thai green
curry rice and fantastic bings with
chili peanut dressing guaranteed to get
the fusses of eaters into greens
I mean Tana ready for Jack's wings holes
gonna have myself a buzzing long chat
with some nice quality guys too oh I
know you're allergic to anything green
how are the beans I've seen you eat more
green bean the last five minutes they
have them the last 10 years now I know
the secret yeah peanut what's run it you
dig into those chicken wings now fingers
right nice very good very nice Jack yeah
they're tasty right there's no dainty
way of Genesis no holy don't worry about
me nail varnish defined in such a lady
[Music]